i enjoy thoughtful reflective
philosophical
uh aaron rodgers what i hope to enjoy
is monday's show because my fear my
fear is that
if tom brady fools around
and goes into lambo
and thereby delivers a home super bowl
to the bucks in his first year with the
bucks
and denies aaron rodgers
a second trip to the super bowl and
hands him a fourth
consecutive nfc championship game loss
that's amazing i don't know that i don't
know that i'm going to want to
come on monday i may not show up here on
monday because i don't want to hear from
what because i think you're going to use
it as a reason
because i just know what's coming if
that if that happens
i know i'm going to have to hear about
how this lets you further
know that those of us who think that the
premier performer at the position
is is not always cracked up to be and we
need to stop disrespecting
the real ghost i just i just i already
can hear it
and i'm just praying that i don't have
to endure that
on monday i don't i don't know i don't
know what color this is showing up on
your screen this is packers i have a
packers green today
this is packers green all about
definitely
it's green it is i am a aaron rodgers
fan i am now in all seriousness i am i'm
an aaron rodgers fan
just having a conversation with somebody
yesterday about rogers and
you know does he need a super bowl to
appear on mount rushmore and all of
all this other stuff would you say and
i'm saying i'm saying
what are we talking about he's already
there he's a great he's a great
quarterback thank you
our argument over aaron rodgers is that
i just don't think that he is the
greatest quarterback
i've ever seen because i just look at
yeah you and you and uh chris sims who's
gonna join us later you and chris sims
keep talking about
some of the aesthetics of playing the
position i've never seen anybody throw a
prettier ball
or never see anybody play the position
you know as well as aaron rodgers
you know there are stats to go along
with this there i mean he's been
productive too oh by the way
i mean not just you know i could throw
it
quarterback and this is where you get
into another category that you don't
love so much
i think it's almost like there are some
categories
of quarterbacking that the stats don't
capture
so there's just something about you know
i don't know if if there's leadership is
there a leadership
stat is there a um
just inspiring uh inspiring people to do
a little bit more than they're capable
of doing
i i don't know if you can if you can
measure that
i think tom brady is just is the best
quarterback
i've ever seen for example and aaron
rodgers probably does this too
the example i'm about to use aaron
rodgers
has probably done this
but uh brady a couple of times so you
remember uh the lineman sebastian
vollmer
yeah yeah left tackle right yeah so
sebastian vollmer said playing with
brady
they would be in the middle of a play
there's something just totally
unscripted
and brady would just direct them
redirect him like within a half second
of the snap
something that something came up
something changed
vulnerable is not seeing it brady's
looking downfield but he also sees what
valmer is dealing with and he'll tell
valmer step to your left
and then throw the football or so when
they say see the field they really mean
you see the whole field
fred taylor told a great story on
brandon marshall's podcast
where they'll call a play out of the
huddle brady calls the play
the play develops and all of a sudden he
goes oh no freddie swing it
that wasn't a quite play call but he
just sees something on the field very
quickly
fred swing i know i didn't tell you to
do that but swinging right now he throw
it to fred
picks up in the midst of the play in the
middle of a crowd screaming
pass rush coming bill like sir you say
backyard football you mean backyard
football not
not drawing up in the dirt in the huddle
like improvising on the fly
off schedule yeah like a mug yeah see
that kind of stuff
that's that's that's next level to me
and that's great aaron rodgers
i'm sure aaron rodgers doesn't i'm not
i'm not trying to slide it i have to say
this to you
yeah no you know i get it i know you
know no we're adults i know you're not i
know this is not
uh uh no we're not doing that i know
what you're saying
i know what you said yeah i know i know
that's not an insult but with that being
said
you don't you don't want the buccaneers
to win this game
because i'm going to be awful on monday
i'm just going to be
i'm going to be terrible i'll come in
wearing a buccaneers jersey
i'll have uh i'll have tom brady
stephanie we're gonna have tom brady
full screens all day
we're gonna have guests tom brady
teammates tom brady roommates
no we're not no we're not but wait but
you know tom brady's dad
wait but wait wait a second i i parked
that just for one second because i do
want to come back to that sentiment i do
want to come back to that but the real
reason i wanted to
get into this and number one i'm i'm
happy to hear and i know we agree on a
lot of things
um but i'm happy to hear
that um you don't view this as some kind
of a
you know proven game for aaron rodgers
that his legacy isn't on the
line i mean we're sports writers you
know we're turned talking heads
journalists so to speak and um
[Music]
you know narratives there's that word
again so drink up
you know narratives uh about aaron
rodgers and
you know only one super bowl and you
know will he be denied
another uh appearance you know lose
another nfc championship game what's
that going to say about him this that
and the other and i just i look and
nobody threw a better ball nobody was a
better quarterback
nobody played the position better uh you
know when i was growing up than dan
marino did and he went
in his second year and never went back
you know uh
i mean again not that it's all about
throwing a pretty pass but warren moon
money through the prettiest ball of all
time never went to a super bowl i mean
it's
it's it's no referendum you know or
or or or black mark against you know
who you are as a leader or a player if
your team doesn't get to the super bowl
i i hate that's why i hate across all
team sports
reducing goat arguments to championships
because
it does not mean that aaron rodgers came
up short
it just didn't happen but but more than
anything michael for whatever reason and
maybe he doesn't play well
but it's it sometimes that's just how it
goes and more than anything michael i
just wanted to use this to
speak on something and i've been
speaking on a lot lately because again
here's that theme
process i've had several conversations
lately with colleagues in
in business and in media where i've
talked about
the process and not just trusting the
process but loving the process
and the process takes place in the
present to go back to aaron rodgers
talking about the present being a gift
the process takes place in the present
and what i love about the process
michael
is that it is the only thing
that we have control over you know how
they say
you know your effort is already 90 uh of
life
you know is is um is is
tipper said is what happens 90 is how i
react to it i think i think i did that
right i hope i didn't butcher that
but bottom line is you know
the process and how we approach our
passion
and our profession is the only thing
that we actually
actually have absolute control over the
results
is external so like your happiness and
your contentment and your peace
is defined by the process because if
you're depending
on the results whether that's a
promotion whether that's a raise
whether that's a win whether that's a
championship
whether that's induction into a hall of
fame whether that's a port surprise
whatever it is if you're dependent on
those things for validation
and for satisfaction you're depending on
external factors and external parties
to bestow those things upon you and you
can't you can't guarantee those things
the only thing you can guarantee is how
you show up to work every day
and how you enjoy it and how much effort
you put forth into what you're
what you're doing and if you're good
with that the results will come
or they won't or they won't so i just
was really
impressed by what aaron rodgers had to
say because i
i believe he's being sincere that it's
not about pressure because pressure
again is external
and that would be him buying into the
notion that he somehow
has to get it done because his clock's
running out and jordan loves on the
sideline
how many more opportunities will he have
it's like if he's thinking about the
next opportunities or perhaps
perhaps the lack thereof then you're not
enjoying this opportunity so i thought
it was really beautiful he has a
beautiful mind to begin with
and i thought it was really beautiful to
sit here and have him just put to rest
this notion
of that this is somehow a moment that he
has
to to capitalize on or else it's like
but you're not enjoying it if
it you know you're not enjoying it if
you're thinking about
what happens and then what people are
going to think and if it's going to
happen again
so yeah it just it just really touched
me it's a beautiful commentary about
about a beautiful mystery
that is his future all of our futures
really so right so you in other words
as as a poet fife said i don't need a
statue to tell me how nice i am right
exactly right yes exactly i started
laughing i thought you gonna say
something else i'm sorry
i think i know you so well i i
preemptively laughed because i thought
you were gonna take gonna
get her to slam me just now i thought
you were gonna say
so in other words michael you're
preparing yourself for when he
inevitably loses on sunday to tom brady
no no no no i'm not gonna say that how
am i gonna say that
um because i actually agree with no
because i agree with you i agree with
what you're saying
and it's i think it's it's important
and we this is what we got to find out
from aaron rodgers and others it's
important to go
into any profession and know why you're
going into it and know what what you
want out of it
and sometimes that answer changes so
sometimes you go into a profession
because
hey i want some recognition or i want to
make a lot of money
and then that changes and you say i
don't really care about the money i love
what i'm doing
uh or i like the way i feel
when i'm doing this it could be a number
of things so for aaron rodgers
maybe at one point he did see winning
championships as validation
and winning super well you certainly he
certainly wants to win mvps
i mean he's talked about he wants to win
the immediate you know what's
interesting
it's interesting that you mentioned the
mvp thing
because i wonder like how we how we view
super bowls and mvps is so is so
um inconsistent but
it's worthy of debate it's worthy of
discussion so
we talk about peyton manning peyton
manning
would he qualify as one of your greatest
quarterbacks ever if not
top three guys top four guys
yeah yeah sure so he won five he won
five mvps and two super bowls
so does if when aaron rodgers wins the
mvp this year i think he's favorite to
win it right
you'll be his third yeah it's only his
third if i would be his fourth okay
so he had three super bowls i mean three
uh mvps
in one and one super bowl title
is that is that the the calculus that
gets you to rush more because peyton is
there he's got two super bowls and five
mvps is it just because he's got five
he had four mvps will we look at peyton
is
less than if he had if he had five mvp
mvps and one fewer uh super bowl win is
that when mvps are subjective by nature
anyway
yeah you know somebody voted it's hard i
i know
it shouldn't all come down to the super
bowl titles as you said
the goat argument shouldn't rest there
but then again
when you have somebody who continues to
win it
whether that's michael jordan basketball
or tom brady
uh in in football or or derek jeter
in baseball and you have these guys who
win it over and over
it's hard to ignore it you can't say
that's the
that's everything but why did he oh
foreign
yeah well especially when
there's a there's a constant you know so
brady does it for all these years
in one place and then he goes to tampa
and they and they're right back where
he's always been which is in the
conference championship game if not
beyond like
you you're right you cannot say oh it's
just all luck and good fortune and
circumstances
when you're clearly the thermostat and
not the thermometer
in the room which tom brady is hey
thanks for watching brother from another
on youtube
make sure you hit subscribe before you
leave and be sure to watch us
3-5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you